it is a flight to reach the caress and
ab cake oil plants the two vast
facilities are both way out in the
desert east of Riyadh and this is the
first time since last weekend's
extraordinary attack that we've been
authorized to see them up close this is
an oil pressure equalization tower it is
a central component of the Kouros plant
and at 3:31 on Saturday morning it was
hit square on by a cruise missile three
other missiles also hit their targets
identical towers none of the workers
here were authorized to talk to us but
off-camera they said how quickly the
emergency services were here and how
fast the fires were out the purpose of
course of all this from Saudi Aramco's
points of view is to demonstrate that
they are back online that they are able
to maintain production and we'll get it
back to to capacity very very soon but
looking at that it is a very very
graphic demonstration of how easily so
much damage was able to be done the
flight to the other plant is a reminder
of just how big this company is it has
its own airline and Saudi Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Salman is eyeing a
valuation target of an extraordinary two
trillion dollars it has a reputation to
uphold and clients globally to reassure
this image of the abbé cake plant was
released in the week by the US
government we were taken first to the
area on the left just like at KU race
direct hits on stabilization towers
clearly intentionally and successfully
targeted this plant is the largest of
its kind in the world the damage done
here cut Saudi oil production in half
and global oil supply by five percent
there's one of the piercings close up
this is a section of one of these large
Spears which are used to separate oil
and gas a critical part of the
infrastructure here and you know walking
around this plant and the other one
what's really really striking is the
accuracy with which the missiles and the
drones hit their targets there is no
collateral damage of anywhere or on
every occasion the targets were hit bang
on
this was about upholding the reputation
of a company that's vital to the global
economy but as America and Saudi Arabia
build their case against Iran it is for
them a demonstration of the threat the
Iranian regime poses mark stone Sky News
in Saudi Arabia